Okay, so this is fairly basic so far. What is all this have to do with CS212.
So in Unit 3, we introduce this memo decorator and the question that's still popping multiple times
in the forums whereas how can a memorize function or specifically, how can multiple memorize functions
all maintained their own separate cache when it appears that cache is defined here
and so let's talk about that.
And as a reminder, memo gets past the function f and returns a new function which we've called _f
that contains this cache and this cache basically prevents us from repeating calculations,
and so the best way to learn anything in programming is still do some experiments.
So I've written a couple of simple functions here filled in square.
Just as a reminder, let's take a look at what our main space
or our global environment looks like like now.
And now what we've done is we head to the global environment bindings between memo
and its respective object and likewise, we filled in square.
Know that we haven't created any new frames yet, any new environments because that doesn't happen
until we actually call a function and we haven't called any of these functions.
All right, so what I'm going to do now is I'm going to memorize these functions by adding
the memo decorator and remember, this is the same--adding this decorator and memo
is the same as saying fib equals memo of fib.
This is just some nice syntactic sugar to put on the element, looks like a little nicer.
And so before we start calling fib and square, I'm going to introduce this print statement into memo
so that we can try to get an idea of what's going on.
So here I'm going to print fib(4) and we can see the cache getting updated as we would expect.
By the end, we will get the result 5 and also have this dictionary contain fib(3), (2), (1) and (0).
So the cache is behaving as expected.
Let's see what happens if I run now while making to print commands to fib(4)
and this is interesting.
The memorization now occurs in the first print statement in the first time we make these calls.
By turning at the second call to fib(4), we already have our cache.
We don't have to do all of these calls to fib. We just get 5. Great!
Now, the big question--is this cache the same as the cache in the square function up here.
You've probably have a good guess at the answer but let's just confirm.
So same thing except when we call square twice and you can see, when I call square the first time,
it's not telling me that the cache is the cache associated with fib--
telling me it's empty as we expect, and when I call the second time, of course, we're all set.
We have this mapping 4 to 16. Good. Now, how does this happen?
Well, the trick is--a new environment isn't created until we call a function.
So what happened here is we called memo and we set at_memo--so when we said at_memo
of fib, we created a new environment what I'm going to call memo.
In this environment, there was a binding from fib to the associated object.
Actually, since I didn't do the update wrapper step that we did in class,
this function name is actually still called _f, but again no separate environment
for _f yet because we didn't call it yet.
Likewise, when I plugged the decorator to square, a new environment was created with its own _f
though this one points to the square function object.
I almost forgot the important part--both of these have their own cache.
Now, when I called fib, that's when this environment was created, and when we called fib,
that's when we created this new environment.
And we can see that when fib goes looking for cache, if it looks in its local environment
and doesn't find one, it moves one step of the hierarchy, finds the cache associated
with this call to memo, uses that, and doesn't care at all about this cache over here.
Just because these have the same name, they live in totally separate environments,
and since fib only has access to everything over here and square could only access
everything over here, there was no correlation, no conflict at all that these both have the name cache
and we can use the memo decorator exactly the way we want to.
Thank you Python. Now, this is a lot to cover in a few minutes.
If you're still confused, feel free to check out the links below on scope and closure,
which is the topic that we didn't get to today--good luck.